was ist heute der anlass für
ich habe mich heute mal über gar nicht
aufgeregt deswegen ich meine noch heute
dem lkw-fahrer widmen möchte den mein
kollege peter wilke beim klima protest
traf
wollen sie uns was dazu sagen
was halten sie davon dass die trinker
von halten ganz ehrlich so absolute
scheiße sie sollen bei den politikern
hochgehen und nicht hier uns und wir
haben alle zu tun sie machen ihren job
ich mache meinen job und das machen die
stören dabei es reicht wir können
zufrieden sein dass ich jetzt ein
schöner effekt habe da sich entspannt
bin von snacks und nach vorne ja
guter mann
der ein wahres wort gelassen aus spricht
also ich weiß genau was er meint ich
gebe ihm total recht weil ich habe mich
auch darüber aufgeregt war habe ich mich
über einen bestimmten aspekt dieser
geschichte aufgeregt nach meiner
wahrnehmung ich habe das in der
abendschau des rbb es erste mal gesehen
dass da so eine kleine kette von vier
fünf leuten quer von abfahrt von der
autobahn saß und ganzen verkehr
aufgehalten hat die berichterstattung
über diese paar hanseln hat dafür
gesorgt dass die nicht mehr aufgehört
haben und es wurde immer wieder nach
berichtet noch mal neu noch mal neu noch
mal wurden immer bedeutender diesen
völlig unbedeutend aber
die haben jetzt eine mediale bedeutung
gewonnen sie haben ja schon mal was
geschafft ja menschen gehungert also bei
herr scholz haben diese klimaprozess ja
schonmal gehungert damit werden sie auch
auf ihrer webseite ein herr scholz
getroffen habe und ich glaube sie haben
einfach zu merken so funktioniert da hat
herr scholz auch nicht drüber geärgert
sondern gar nicht hingeguckt aber die
lkw fahren die autofahrer die irgendwas
vorhaben es gibt ja nicht mehr so viele
leute in berlin die neue arbeit
nachgehen das hat nicht mal weniger aber
ein paar gibt es schon auch die kommen
damit der autobahn reingefahren aus
brandenburg haben etwas zu erledigen und
stehen da und gucken auf fünf sechs
leute die quer über die straße sitzen
und das ist aus meiner sicht ein ganz
schädlicher ausschließlicher medien
effekt die sind es nicht wert über sie
zu berichten wenn wir eine ordentliche
klima eine große klima demonstration in
berlin haben wo 10.000 leute rum gehen
völlig andere geschichte
das verstehe ich gut aber die nicht es
trifft auf jeden fall die falschen würde
ich auch sagen wir sitzen da ich bin
schon fast sagen wohlstands verwahrlost
es ist ein zeichen von spätrömischer
dekadenz und möchten irgendwie wegen
essen usw darauf hinweisen was hier
schiefläuft sollen supermärkte gehen
oder von lässt nicht erklären wir noch
mal ganz kurz dagegen
dagegen habe ich die demonstrieren dafür
dass essen nicht vergeudet wird aber
weiter an die krankenpflegerin geht es
irgendwie zu ihrem 80-jährigen patientin
muss oder die mutter die ihr kind vom
kindergarten abholen will dagegen tun
oder was kann die denn dafür und da
trifft definitiv die falschen und es
wird auch den unmut weiter befeuern dass
die leute sagen was sind das für spinner
kennt man die überhaupt die spinner nein
es sind jedes mal wenn es nur sieben
oder acht leute sind also in münchen
würde die polizei kommen würde sie dann
hoch heben wenn sie an sich wie
festgeklebt richtig festgeklebt war
nicht so leicht
sind wirklich ja gewisse war das ist ja
auch
ich glaube nur dass das man aussehen
muss
machen wir einmal für eine sekunde dreht
wie immer wohlwollend gegenüber sie
wollen auf etwas aufmerksam machen
ich habe immer noch die worte meiner 16
jährigen tochter im ohr papa wie radikal
muss man eigentlich sein wenn man was
verändern will muss man dann eigentlich
radikaler sein als man eigentlich sein
will muss man eine sehr schwer und ich
habe als ich diese wohlstands für
wahllisten leute da gesehen habe habe
ich erwischt ist im kopf gehabt die
haben sich für einen weg entschieden auf
was aufmerksam zu machen und haben dabei
übersehen dass wenn man wirklich etwas
verändern will braucht man am ende ja
mehrheiten hinter sich genau und nicht
gegen sie und sie haben den weg gewählt
ausgerechnet um alle gegen sich
aufzubringen
und damit es geschafft dass man das
weswegen sie möglicherweise vielleicht
sogar mit einer guten absicht sich auf
die straße kleben ja gar nicht mehr
wahrnimmt das ist voll weil anderen hat
ja auch mit dem ziel des protests dem
ort des prozess überhaupt nichts und wer
also wert ist und da wenn es ihnen darum
geht dass lebensmittel nicht
verschwendet werden da müssen sie zu
großen lebensmittelketten zur zentrale
oder großen märkten und die mülltonnen
gucken und dort mal hier noch s-bahn
salate und sonstwas haus ziehen und
zeigen gucken was macht mir mut und
müssen sie reingehen und den film aber
nicht im berufsverkehr stoppen das ist
unmöglich dastehen ich meine die
gehandelt und die wären hätten und
geradezu gezwungen ihr pausenbrot
aufzuessen werden sie da sitzen und
verschwenden nichts ja sie haben auch
mit dem problem irgendwann aber damit
gewinnt man keine mehrheiten wenn man
wirklich ein gutes anliegen hat was ist
ja sein kann dann ist das der falsche
weg da bringt man die leute gegen sich
auf und ich glaube die mehrheit in
deutschland findet diese leute jetzt
einfach nur peinlich und völlig daneben
und sie werden keine potter mit
gewinnzusagen gelungen die medien zu
queren überhaupt da
stirn den sechs leute muss man nicht
über bei anderen natürlichen wir sind
total verständlich muss man darüber
berichten wollen dass abweichende
verhalten der rww tut das gerne da
stehen sechs leute der linkspartei auf
irgend einer brücke ragenden die s bahn
schienen müssen anders gelegt wird der
sand in einer kleinen haben sich
kamerateam den zwei das treiben wohl
nicht mehr geben die meinung erfahren
der dritten journalist sind hier und
sollte meine uhr berichten ja oder nein
frau riekel
also wir journalisten berichten ja über
alles was irgendwie aufsehen erregt und
was das leben irgendwie spannend macht
also ich finde schon dass man darüber
berichten muss und irgendwo wenn ich
jetzt in allen zuhörer denke ich mich
abriss pack von diesem 67 typen die sich
auch noch fest passen mehr und hier
reden wir
reden schon ganz lange im jahr wir sind
und auf ihre tochter hat gesagt genau
wie radikal muss ich eigentlich sein um
etwas zu bewegen ich weiß nicht das ist
vielleicht es ist tatsächlich eine sache
wir medien könnten natürlich dass jetzt
benutzen und positiv darüber berichten
was sie eigentlich wollen nämlich zum
beispiel lebensmittelverschwendung wie
er tatsächlich ein großes problem in
deutschland ist also irgendwo finde ich
haben haben wir jetzt schon
gesellschaften radikale also außerhalb
von den lebensmitteln wollen sie auch
hin zu einer agrarwirtschaft ja gut und
dementsprechend fiel auch dem kind ihre
träume ich bin mit dem brummifahrer
rübenschnitzel gut ich habe es immer so
gut beschäftigt
wenigstens sozusagen ist entspannt
werden glaubt haut die nicht um aber wie
radikal muss man denn sein um was zu
verändern ja ich glaube so radikal muss
man sein denn wir reden ja darüber und
die sanften proteste also in münchen
gibt es jeden samstag einen
autokorso gegen den gegen den impfzwang
und hunderte von autos das heißt die
prinzregentenstraße und maximilianstraße
ist alles gesperrt in der surf und da
muss man dann auch lange warten und das
und ich finde die münchner schauen
freundlich zu und sagen recht hat er und
gut so und jetzt macht mal ein bisschen
schneller es ist aber nicht wirklich
radikal mit markus söder mitfahren
das ist vielleicht auch gegen
ihn sogar an dem auto aber so bald
wieder papst wenn ich noch nicht ja aber
man könnte natürlich den trachtenumzug
zum oktoberfest im könnte man natürlich
umfunktionieren denn so ein protest
umzug yamamoto hoffen da ist es klar zu
sagen
dabei hoffen derweil dass man diesen
vorbei ist auf dem weg aus der
landtagswahlen wir hatten noch nie
gewesen
außerdem der auffassung dass man
selbstverständlich großveranstaltungen
stattfinden lassen also ich und ich
etwas weil ihr alle der meinung seid
darüber muss man berichten über fünf
leute also
was wichtig und was nicht